(anxious music)
- [Reporter] Take a look at this map.
It shows the change in coronavirus cases
over the past two months.
You can see cases arising.
And as the weather gets colder
and people had back indoors,
experts say it could get worse.
- As we get through the
fall and into the winter
with the holiday season going,
we've got to do something different.
- [Reporter] Experts
warn that many buildings,
like restaurants, schools, and homes,
are not equipped with the
ventilation and filtration systems
needed to reduce the spread of COVID-19.
- So, by now, people are really familiar
with masking, hand-washing, distancing,
but fewer people are
aware that ventilation
and filtration really matter.
- [Reporter] It's now
clear that the coronavirus
travels through the air,
which is why indoor
gatherings can be so deadly.
The virus can accumulate in aerosols,
tiny droplets that gather in the air,
as we breathe and talk.
- That virus is never naked
in the air, is what we say.
It's always floating
in respiratory droplets
that are much bigger.
- [Reporter] Indoors,
those particles can add up,
increasing the risk of transmission.
And one way to mitigate that
is to pump in fresh air
with a ventilation system.
- We have to think about
the thermal conditions
like humidity and temperature,
but also just how much
outdoor air is moving in.
For me, the priority is to
increase the air exchange rate.
- [Reporter] The air exchange rate
determines how many times an hour
fresh air circulates through a building.
There's not an exact recommended rate,
but experts say that three
to six exchanges per hour
is ideal.
But good flow of fresh
air is only one part
of preventing the indoor
spread of the coronavirus.
The other is filters,
and experts recommend
using one called HEPA.
This type of pleated mechanical filter
is made from fiberglass, foam or cotton.
It can remove more than
99% of airborne particles,
including those carrying
viruses like the coronavirus.
This is the same type of filter
used in hospitals and airplanes,
but there has been some confusion
over whether or not HEPA filters
can effectively capture
airborne coronavirus.
That's because these filters
are rated for particles
that are 0.3 microns in size,
larger than the coronavirus.
People assume that they
don't catch anything smaller,
but that's just not true.
- Filters are rated for the particle size
they perform worst at,
and that's 0.3 microns.
As you get to bigger particles,
and even smaller particles,
the HEPA filter will
capture closer to 100%.
- [Reporter] Because the
coronavirus tends to travel
in droplets that are
larger than 0.3 microns,
HEPA filters can capture
almost all of them.
The virus also travels in
droplets that are smaller,
and HEPA filters can capture those too.
- Filters work not by straining out things
that are larger than the holes in them,
but they actually work by
trapping particles in the air
as the air flows around the
different fibers in the filter.
- [Reporter] When very small aerosols
bump into gas particles, they
move in a random pattern.
That is called Brownian motion.
- Kind of like a drunk person
stumbling around in the dark.
And because of that random motion,
they can crash into the fibers.
- [Reporter] The harder
it is for particles
carrying viruses to pass through a filter,
the lower the chance
of viral transmission.
But the problem is that not every building
has a system that can handle them.
- When you have a air system moving air
through the building, and
then it runs through a filter,
you can imagine that a
higher-efficiency filter
that's more tightly woven
is going to be harder to push air through.
Very few systems can push
air through a HEPA filter
unless it's designed that way,
because HEPA is the most
efficient filter we have.
- [Reporter] That is why experts recommend
that schools, businesses and homes
use a different type of
lower-efficiency filter called MERV.
- If you can get up to
something called MERV-13,
that's able to remove 80% or more
of viruses that might be in the air.
- [Reporter] This is important
because this type of filter
can be installed in standard
ventilation systems,
like what you might have in your home.
Still, there are plenty of buildings
that aren't able to adapt
this type of filter either.
- Many people are starting
to realize for the first time
that their buildings can't respond.
Their systems are not dynamic,
they're not resilient,
they can't increase capacity.
- [Reporter] Older and underfunded schools
face some of the biggest challenges.
According to the U.S. Government
Accountability Office,
41% of districts need to update or replace
their ventilation system in at
least half of their schools,
which adds up to about
36,000 schools nationwide.
The Washington D.C. public school system
spent $24 million on upgrades
to handle higher-efficiency filters
in preparation for the return
of students and teachers.
And it's not just pricey for schools.
Some restaurants that will
need to spend over $30,000
to upgrade their systems, in
addition to operating costs.
- You pay more for energy
to bring in more outdoor
air and condition it,
and also work harder, your
system will work harder
to push air through a
higher-efficiency filter.
- [Reporter] The air pumped into buildings
also needs to be cooled or heated,
which adds to energy bills.
Even though not every building
can afford to make these adjustments,
experts say there are other solutions.
For older buildings with outdated systems,
opening windows is a good, cheap option.
But in the winter, this
isn't always possible,
and some buildings have
windows that are sealed shut.
- If you can't hit the targets,
consider supplemental air cleaning
through the use of a portable air cleaner
with a HEPA filter.
Now, if you size these
correctly for the room,
for restaurant, a school
classroom, a bedroom at home,
you can get four, five or
six air changes per hour
of clean air, and it
can be cost-effective.
- [Reporter] That's what the
DC public school system did,
in addition to upgrading
their ventilation systems.
The bottom line, we know
that the coronavirus
can spread through the air,
and we know how to reduce
the risk of transmission.
The biggest hurdle will be the cost
of putting the science into action.
(bouncy sting music)